okay we've started live streaming
so welcome everybody to
today's april 5th extraordinary
infrastructure meeting
i'm going to start with the apologies
for this meeting we have
councillors sopa
councillor crackit
and jeff grant
and i have no
i've had no word from counselor kit so
moved councillor second
put that all those in favor
zooming we have councillor clark
councillor abbott we have michael day
rhiannon suda and hayden powell
uh on that mr german i'm afraid i'm like
the emperor with no clothes i can't have
a camera
you're in the all together okay
i'm not quite but i just don't have any
filter on the camera no that's okay as
long as your audio is good and if you
just just interrupt if you do want to
say something if you can
thank you so much okay
um
right let's move on to the deliberations
of the roading and traffic by law
speed review
now uh russell and david would you like
to
come up to the table
what i'd like to do is if you can talk
us through the process that's happened
we've got the resolutions in front of us
the recommendations
um
and i think if
after you've given us a brief i'd like
for you to
dwell down on each of the main
recommendations which are five six seven
eight nine ten eleven just
just to cover them off so
uh that provides clarity
um to all of those and then we can ask
some questions and move through them
thanks
thanks mr chairman and good afternoon
and thank you for the opportunity to
present this report which is our roading
and traffic bylaw
following the speed review consultation
we have rhiannon and
hayden
on the zoom call um and they form from
they are from our strategic and strategy
and policy team and david mccormick to
my right who's our road asset engineer
who is
my technical advisor i'm on speed so
he's he's the man who knows most about
speed
um and they will be able to help us with
some questions as we go through i
thought it may be helpful to run briefly
run through a yes our process a little
bit and what we've seen and what we
understand so perhaps just put a little
bit of flavor on there so i just have
got some comments on the recommendations
just how we've structured them and what
they mean
i think it's worthwhile just having a
little bit of a
overview on what the consultation
process from our viewpoint
and david will run through a couple of
examples that hopefully will give you
some insight about how we see this could
actually run it run across
and they'll look at some of those
options
what we do know is that more than one
person per day dies on a road in new
zealand
and this is not improving
speed has proven to be a direct factor
in most crashes we see across the
country
because the faster we go the bigger the
mess that's something that we do know
but speed is something that council in
our community can have a direct um input
into
and consequently this review has some
importance to our community
we're consulting because we need to
change the uh the roading bylaw
and this is a this is the opportunity
for the community to have input and to
start supporting
that change
we think this speed review will be the
biggest change that some of our
community will see in a while it's quite
a big change
and it will have the will have impacts
potentially on some of the day-to-day
activities i think some people will
believe that the changes that are being
proposed will have a greater impact but
david will hopefully be able to show
some of those speed changes won't
dramatically change their travel times
what we do believe is that from this
the roads will become safer
because we know that with less speed so
the impact of crashes decreases
what we are proposing in general terms
is some changes around schools
some changes for our unsealed roads for
our rural sealed roads
but we aren't proposing
at the moment to actually change any of
our 50 kilometer in our roads
brief comments about our recommendation
we can work a little bit deeper into
those later on
um recommendation 5 really just sets out
the principles that we're actually
suggesting that council look to adopt
that
that helps support decisions in the
future so we're not neces that those
principles don't necessarily have any
direct impact but it will actually
assist on future decision making
recommendation six has quite a few
um sections to it but that is actually
the specific changes to those speeds so
that we can take
the the direction from this meeting and
actually prepare
changes to the the riding bylaw and
return it
for the may meetings for its
consideration and they are
deliberately grouped by location or by
type so for instance you'll see all the
schools in one section um
and in tables you'll see all the uh
unsealed roads where we're proposing to
change those speed from 100.
section 7 is
so recommendation 7 deals with the
roading bylaw you will hopefully recall
that there were some elements of the
bylaw we had some small changes we had a
submission that pointed out there was
some grammatical and other minor changes
to the by-law which we think are helpful
um and we are proposing to change some
of those it also includes don street
proposing it to go
back to two-way um i've called that out
a little bit of our tidy up section
and recommendations eight to ten are
really changes um
that we don't want to miss um some of
them are to do with proposed
subdivisions as we go forward so
inverary and
others
a little bit about consultation
what we what we found um i think the
consultation we've run for this process
is probably the most extensive
um consultation that i've seen um
dealing with any roading metaphor for
since i've been around
hayden and rhiannon's team
have engaged widely
through many opportunities
through facebook through meetings
and i do appreciate the support we had
from the councillors who came to those
meetings and helped us um through
adatara through morris bush and all the
other meetings and it was really good um
we got a lot from those people sometimes
there weren't lots of people at them but
they were certainly that support was
appreciated i think there were 180 sorry
198 submissions and i guess
from our viewpoint is
how well is the community actually
attached to us we think that's
a good representative sample
we have
consulted with the bigger players so
people like waku katahi the new zealand
police the aaa
heavy haulage
those are organisations who have quite
an imp this change will have quite an
impact on them so
one of the things that we do want to
start a conversation that actually talks
about what is a safe and appropriate
speed and i think david will want to
talk about that and that's really what
the basis of this is what is the safe
speed we should be driving on our roads
and rather than us talking about what's
the legal speed limit we should be
actually starting to address what is the
safe what is a safe and appropriate
speed
so as i mentioned earlier
for urban streets we still believe those
are streets where um
streets need to also be for people at
the moment they're very card dominated
and we do actually need to start to
think about and that's what the prints
will start to address
i think there's a big challenge to our
wider pop population to actually
understand what
what we're driving at and there will be
some more communication needed
schools well we know that it was
that's pretty much what we would
describe as a no-brainer
that we actually
have wide acceptance from it i think we
generally got lots of support
variable speeds at school so they're
only those speed changes are only when
the kids are coming in and out seems to
be
pretty well accepted as a good idea out
there in the community
as i mentioned earlier it will be
from this meeting your direction will we
will feed into that by-law and we'll
bring that
by-law back to the may council for
adoption i guess that's another
opportunity
to actually see and hear what's being
proposed in there
we do recognize that we will need a
reasonably significant communications
plan that actually will work over time
so that actually as we do things we can
communicate it well to the community
and i think it's useful for david just
to perhaps run through a couple of a
couple of examples for us to sort of
explain how this how we see this working
so it gives you a good bit of an insight
thank you russell so just to jump into
back to section six uh we've got all of
our
speed changes that we're looking to
implement um so to start off with one of
those uh is our rural sealed roads that
generally speaking we are looking to
drop them from 100 down to 80 k's an
hour
these are the ones that i think a lot of
people uh are thinking is going to
impact sorry david can you just bring
the mic a little bit closer thanks
is that better yeah perfect um so these
are the roads that we're looking uh yeah
to reduce from 80
down to 80 from 100
the other roads that
everyone believes will increase their
travel time by a lot so to speak about
the the main one that's hot topic at the
moment which is odata road bay road um
currently if the proposal along that
section of road is 60 uh from duns road
through uh until all of the residential
stuff ends which has got a lot busier
with more driveways more residents
through there and then 80k an hour
through to bay road and then bay road to
stay
at 80k an hour back to the 50.
what we are proposing is only going to
add 38 seconds onto the travel time so
it's not actually adding a long time
it's adding 38 seconds
onto the travel time but you're going to
arrive where you're going to arrive to
so it's not actually
you're going to impact your day too much
as russell touched on before we need to
learn about what the safe and
appropriate speed is not just the speed
limit the speed limit is what everyone
in new zealand has thought is the safe
speed but it's not with all the hazards
that are on our roads so the safe and
appropriate speed is what we've chosen
for those types of roads
to go from there the schools
again the schools are an easy one we had
a very good number of people agreeing
that we need to do the schools and do
the schools as soon as possible and so
these are going to be at a variable
speed limit of 30 outside of our urban
schools with 60 outside of our rural
schools
to touch on one school in particular one
section of road herbert street outside
boys high
we understand that that's a very busy
section that already operates at below
30 k's an hour because it is extremely
busy we have pedestrians everywhere the
boys are just crossing where they choose
to
the only thing that we need to
understand from that area is we're
actually going to impact the side roads
um so we're not going to impact queen's
drive because that's an important road
for us but all of the likes of lewis
street ramreg roads we're going to go
about 150 metres into those roads as
well and so just understanding it's not
going to be just the road that the
school is on there are going to be other
side
roads that will be impacted
and then to go to our shopping areas um
shopping areas that we have of south
city cbd as well as windsor
these places are already operating below
the posted speed limit because they are
very tight very um congested in those
things so
the one to talk about here is south city
so at the moment we understand that
there's a pedestrian crossing there that
is
not the nicest cross across because
sometimes cars don't see you as they're
driving so uh that is one of the reasons
why that area is going to get a 30k an
hour uh speed limit through there which
also includes traffic calming at the
same time so we couldn't just implement
a speed change we'll do some speed bumps
um to help slow that traffic down to
make it safer for those pedestrians
crossing through there
and then the fourth
part to do with our recommendation six
is the rural gravel roads which were
reducing the majority from 100 down to
60.
and the area i'm going to talk about
today is our rural bay road which is
currently 100k road
that we are looking to reduce uh down to
60 with a section to 40. um the section
that we've proposed at 40 is where the
rate payers have come in and we've got i
believe it's 16 out of 16 residents down
there have asked for the section outside
of their properties to be reduced to 40
um and due to everyone that lives there
there's actually no through traffic
apart from the quarries um we've
suggested that as well as there's a 25k
in our bin in that section of road so
you shouldn't be traveling
over that 40 anyway so
the reason we're reducing the speeds on
gravel uh is again the safe and
appropriate speed because that is where
a lot of our crashes happen on gravel
roads
it also does a few other things for the
residents along there like dust
suppression
and those kind of things
okay thank you for that um just a
question uh regarding recommendation
five
how what would be the process
for implementing one of the principles
say you wanted to
introduce that
um do you come back to this committee
and
or do you just you just tell us this
happening type thing do you sort of
request
mr chair
any change to the um to a biller will
require a formal resolution of coming
back through council
um to actually get that approved and i
guess the the principles really um help
start that conversation both with
council
it gives the give
the elected members i guess a good
understanding to be able to communicate
to others that how it works but it also
gives good steer to the community
where we're headed
okay council adelaide
thanks chair um look a question about
recommendation nine which is the spread
limit of 50 kilometers implemented for
depor y
um does that take care of the submission
we had
around the the speed limit at the
entrance to the mud i note your comments
about footpaths but it was the question
about the speed limit
so i can touch on that one so
no that does not specifically but after
the um comments that we had i have
pushed the speed limit of the 50 past um
so as part of the proposal that you'll
see at the next council meeting it will
be past the mirai it won't just be a
macmillan it'll be further along so that
has been dealt with
council lewis thank you
david just one we did have a
presentation by one lady who works at
the school in
the north winds in actual fact
in the schedule here it's got 91
children street which is the official
front door address it is on the clock
council lewis can you please um sorry
there are some schools that have more
than one
street frontage through which children
would enter are you looking at the at
the whole cube for those sort of schools
yes so that's just how i talked about
those side streets absolutely it's
basically all of the school
roads around it will be and you'll get
maps at the uh at the council meeting
showing what the extensive so those are
the school one side isn't herbicide yep
so herbert street wins the street as
well as charms of track next day we just
need a classification thank you thanks
councillor skelt thank you to you cheer
um thanks david and russell for
comprehensive report just from
simplicity point of view having read all
the information would it be
moving forward
from the
or the user the road user would it be
easier if we simply just had
a rural speed and an inner city speed as
in
two as opposed to human behavior is
really interesting how we all behave and
given the complication of variances i'm
just really interested in you and your
knowledge because you have a lot of
history and a lot of experience
going forward would that be a would that
be a reasonable
way to move
mr chair i think
part of that is in the rural sense you
end up with seal and unsealed two
different types of road surfaces and i
think that you actually each of those
areas you need to consider slightly
differently so and i guess that's really
why we were trying to
have a reasonably static set like for
unsealed roads at 60 but in specific
cases you could vary it and and sign
those but in
in all essence we're really suggesting
60 on unsealed roads and 80 on this
rural sealed roads and that is
trying for for councillor scout for
exactly that try to keep it so we don't
end up with
a whole lot of variable speeds you know
when you when you travel on a road the
speed needs to be able you need to be
able to read what the environment you
are in and i guess that's with where in
urban environments you've got to be able
it's got to tell you what you're
supposed to be traveling at so at the
moment um 100 just feels too fast in
some places so really if it's an 80k
speed you've got it it's got to feel
like 80. so people will naturally start
to progress to that as we learn better
driver behaviour
and i think that's everybody and their
future drivers so david for the inner
city one particular speed would be an
advantage
it depends on the function of the street
so again i agree with russell
yeah yeah so it's it's about the
readability of the street that if if you
have one that has more place function
then it should be a slower speed than
the other it all depends how
the road does read
thank you uh thank you council scout
before i take councillor clark can i
remind all
all members that we have to have a mask
on
please
um
yeah
thank you
uh your worship we have to have a mask
on in this room
i was going to be speaking let you know
sorry i am mask accent oh you mask
exempt right
i did not realize that
okay if you are exempt that is fine
well
thank you mr chair i
fell that
felt that there was
nobody what is this a question about the
masks
no
sorry is this a question about wearing a
mask
uh no no sorry i've got council clark
next and councillor arnold and i can put
you in the list after that your worship
thank you
council clerk sorry about the delay
thank you chair just a couple of issues
uh just commenting a little bit about uh
councillor skelt's issue about
potentially having one rule for all and
the rural areas um
as most of you'll be aware i've done a
rural delivery run and
when you start talking about um
seal versus unseal
and when you talk about unsealed there
are differences within the unsealed and
some roads you can quite nicely go down
80 cage and others are a nightmare at 40
and 50k so i like the approach that
we're doing it by by design on the race
i just wanted to reinforce that um i
have a couple of specific questions um
one is around the mirai
footpath that was raised russell and
david
you mentioned in the report that
that portion of footpath could be about
100 000 case
and it talks about looking at other
solutions but i mean i can't relate to
what a 100 000
k
100 000 k's footpath actually looks like
is that would that be an excessive
amount to extend the footpath
uh no so the value was put there because
there is also stormwater work that needs
to be done there is a there was a large
road ditch that needs to be sorted to be
able to put a footpath there so that is
why it is excessive for an urban
footpath that you would see but
not in that instance okay mr that's why
we're suggesting there are alternatives
because clearly
what we're trying to promote is access
to the mirai and whether there are some
other internals that avoid having to
pipe ditches and do those sorts of
things that actually make better sense
in terms of access as is what that i
guess the future that design would look
like to actually work collectively on
that
so just a brief expansion on that so
given that the new subdivision that's
going further down from the right
will there be some need to have a foot
path coming right up past the mirai and
back up to regent street
at some later stage
mr chair
not totally familiar with the design but
we do need to make sure we've got some
decent accessibility and connections
that's the whole
purpose if we want to encourage active
transport we need to make sure that
people can get to all the facilities
i know that the
proposal does connect nicely and through
walkways onto regent street so
i'm also anticipating that there'll be
the opportunity to connect up to sky
street in the mirai
okay thank you and just just a final
reflection or really a question on on
page seven of board books which talks
about
some of the risks that we have
russell and i just wanted to clarify is
is the static
um
speed camera on otaro road the only one
we've got in town
uh mr chair that's that's correct that's
that camera is the um managed by the new
zealand police currently
okay
why i asked that russ always is because
we've got a lot of feedback on the these
submissions about
people wanting us to focus quite a bit
on education of drivers as opposed to
just slapping you speed limits and i
just wondered how the enforcement agency
which would be the police i guess
will cope with that sort of desirable or
is it just going to be a
mandated date when the
the limits will go from a to b
mr chair we also have a degree of um i
guess interest in how the police will
encourage the right behavior from people
and that's something that we've been
having conversations with them about the
need to actually i guess contribute to
that education and also we're
necessarily
encourage or have enforcement where
where people aren't
um
[Music]
meeting our expectations i guess so um
speed cameras are things that i know
that nztea or waku katahi have actually
talked about bringing out more across
the country but they're typically volume
based from them and and they currently
control where those cameras go
sure
just a last reflection see russell and
david i think this is a really good
piece of work
and i think while we'll get resistance
from some members of the community we'll
have that anyway
and i was pleased that we left the
urban limit at 50 at this stage
but with the potential to review at a
later stage i think there was an
excellent piece of
piece of work as well thank you
thank you council client councillor
arnold yeah i've got a couple of couple
of questions too russell um
can we just uh just go a little bit
nicer
bearing in mind that we um
we're always wanting public
consultation and participation in
council affairs
the fact that 60
didn't want any change at all and
67
67
um
didn't want the country runs to go below
80
uh if you combine that with them and
then have you taken that into account
at all in any of your
um what your recommendations
um mr chair we've looked closely at a
the number of submissions and i guess we
also see
quite often the silent majority
but we've also looked at what those
people's submissions were relating to
whether it was
their travel time or those sorts of
things and i guess that's what people's
perceptions are very much
that us changing the speed limit will
actually have a huge adverse effect on
their travel time whereas
the information and data that we have
shows that their
current travel speeds are actually
slower than the speed limit anyway
okay
with the um proposal that you might have
uh various speed limits in town you know
like
30 40 50 in different streets do you not
think that just like what happened
when signs were missed um
you might get people missing signs like
they
they might be thinking about something
else and not see the sign that says this
road's actually 40 and suddenly they
perhaps the ticket for doing 50 if
there's no cars around bear in mind i do
drive a lot on the roads around town
myself personally and at times there are
no cars and 50 is quite a safe speed
um
yeah like what would you call it sign
fatigue or something um
miss knowing
mr chair it's a really it's a really
good question about but once again it
comes back to that statement that it
says that our streets need to read the
speed to traveling so for instance the
speeds we have for the city center
changes as in s street at one speed and
um don and parts of calvin street being
proposed to 30ks those streets when you
drive down them you need to those
streets need to to look like that speed
um whereas
at the moment
the rest of our roads that are big and
wide look like the 50ks so that's partly
what drive was driving our
[Music]
suggestion that we leave them there and
if in the future the
the um i guess the community seeks for a
lower speed in their residential areas
we will also need to address that to
make sure that as you drive off the main
road into a residential street that
those areas have other treatments as
part of an ongoing program that actually
make you feel like you're driving there
and you want to slow down because you're
expecting kids to be playing in the
street you know so for instance if
you're driving down queens drive
um you wouldn't expect
kids necessarily to be playing all over
it but if you're turning off queens
drive into a residential street through
some traffic calming
you would
you would naturally change your speed
down so i i think the signage will be
one thing um
unfortunately
um we do have a lot of signs and i guess
that's why we are quite particular about
limiting the number of signs out there
but once again it's just a factor of i
guess their driving ability that we need
to be observant of what speed limits
there are in future cars i am absolutely
certain we'll have some devices to tell
you that you're actually traveling too
fast in an area
i think that technology could be a great
help in the future
also um
do you have any statistics on
you know and arriving at your
suggestions and i actually agree with
some of them don't get me wrong not all
negative yet but
um what percentage just relies on you
know
of the accidents and
fatalities and things actually
contributed by just bad behavior and
irrespective of any signage
uh would that go away do you have a
statistic on that like what percentage
of accidents are contributed to actually
bad behavior and perhaps which could be
fixed by education and or
bigger penalties or something
one of the things that we see is that
um i guess the the approach to crashes
nowadays isn't necessary to find the
person the the reason at fault i guess
all crashes have a number of
contributing factors so often
and the investigations from the police
that they undertake
they attribute it to a number of factors
and one of the things that we and you're
right some some of us that driver and
attention
but speed seems the speed is one of
those things that keeps reappearing
certainly in a rural sense speed
is would signage fix that with those
particular people because i would i
would i think i had a statistic actually
at the moment but it says that it
wouldn't actually change that much
no signage won't decide itself
it it assists a number of
people but
i guess some of the people who don't
obey the current speed are highly
unlikely to obey a new speed but
as part of a driving behavior we'll
actually get there if we actually start
this process
seeing the last question um
see sdc aren't doing anything with the
uh currently with the gravel roads it i
mean i kind of agree with slowing down
the speeds on gravel roads to be fair i
mean i very rarely have a driver
a hundred well i knew i never would in
fact would it not be an idea to actually
do it in conjunction with them so that
there was no so like you know
you're uniting that's going to happen
um yes so we have engaged with uh sdc
about it but no they are not looking uh
at doing the
area-wide speed limit review anytime
soon they've been out recently and
they've got feedback that they don't
want to go back to an area-wide um the
bigger difference between our gravel
roads and their gravel roads are the
distances so their gravel roads are
actually used as arterials or like
roots whereas for us ours are just
connecting roads people though to be
fair wouldn't know if their airs or
these you know you know what i mean yeah
so that's not they go into each other
yeah so that's also the same as the
sealed roads all of those connecting
roads whether it be to wakako tahi state
highway network or our cstc's network um
unfortunately there are going to be
signs that are put up there because
the only way we'd be able to do that
cleanly is do the whole south island and
one go and we just won't be able to do
that so that's why we have spoken with
those other stakeholders and
unfortunately
where roads go into their roads and
places and so you can have a different
different speed yeah on the same road
yeah i do see conditions
i do see that there'll be a growing
challenge across all the local
authorities to address speed um that
certainly is something that's on high in
the mukherte and the government's
interest of how do we actually reduce
our um broad deaths and speed is
is one of those key levers that we have
relatively easy access to to deal with
um so
sdcs
they dealt with the hot spots through
through the i guess the change of speed
from um highways into their towns and
stuff but they will have a wider
question and
two more questions quick questions
almost uh
you must have noticed that the winds are
speed humps
is there any uh thought to to to do
those you might have actually mentioned
a minute ago i think did you in the
south city
because they actually work don't they
because you couldn't drive through there
at more than 30 k's otherwise your car
would have no suspension i would i'd
call them platforms david might call
them speed bumps oh they're sort of
platforms up and down both ways you know
yeah we want to man we want to manage
the speed so as you you enter those
areas that you you
it makes sense to slow down to drive
over them interestingly the people of uh
the windsor area have learned over the
20 something years they've been there um
so
it's a it's interesting their speed was
reduced quite greatly but people have
got cunning in the last little while and
have learned how to drive them a bit
faster but that's just the style of you
playing over 30 because yes
and it's quite it's quite effective what
about um is there any
they're not pedestrian crossings but
some people mistake those for pedestrian
crossings they think they're safe to
cross here but it's actually not it's a
thought to set position crossings
so that's really what that 30 k's an
hour is as well that it's to try and
make it a pedestrian space so that the
street is for people not just the
vehicles at 30 k's an hour um the risk
of a serious or death accident if you
were hit by a car is extremely low
compared to 40 it's very high there's
only one pedestrian crossing yeah and
that's up in the new world so it's to
try and make it almost a shared space so
that people do to do feel as if they can
cross but yes we do understand that
there are some confusion about where to
cross along there can i be really clear
the speed platforms at windsor are not
pedestrian crossings and
and have a pedestrian crossing in the
windsor area will need them to be mid
block like the other one and
unfortunately as a consequence of that
you need visibility for those crossings
which reduces parking and that's the
original
concern the
retailers had some years ago so
but and i guess it's we do get that
periodically where people suggest that
it's um
they get confused but it really needs to
be emphasized there not pedestrian
crossings think russell that's all i've
got at the moment
okay uh next is your worship followed by
councillor abbott
yes
thank you mr chair the um
uh there's obvious that no brain is like
schools and that and
there's obviously a lot of support for
that
but um
it seems to me i i can't help agreeing a
bit with some councillor arnold that
there's not really a significant
demand
to
radicalize changes
that this
report suggests
council rabbit
oh thank you for that i just have a
quick question i noted that uh over a
period of time i think it might be four
to five years uh costs and could amount
to about 20 million dollars i'm just
interested to know that uh we as a city
would we qualify for any subsidy from um
national government
thanks mr chair
we looked at that cost and we would
believe that's a contribution we would
need to put in forward programs should
you want to
implement
40 kilometer an hour across all of your
residential streets and that's the cost
that we would anticipate putting some
calming at all of the intersections i
think you would look at how you would
manage that because that's a pretty
significant sum of money over a period
of time
um the short answer is yes we would hope
that would be subsidized if we can get
it into a program and get it approved
right thank you for that
okay any further questions comment site
yes counselor
sorry we've moved to comments
um
initially i was
of a similar mind as councillor skelton
that i
thought the easiest way through the
problem is to have some sense of
uniformity
one of the challenges that that presents
is
the likes of crescents an unmarked
crescent like um
conway crescent
where legally you can hit around there
at 50 kilometers per hour now and you
can have parking on both sides and
there's really once there's cars on both
sides of the road only sufficient room
for one vehicle to go through
and for a vehicle to navigate that at 50
kilometers per hour is
hazardous and that's just one example of
the street so i saw
good sense in in trying to find
um
a way of dealing with
that issue uh we had really good
feedback from people around the the
schools and there was an excellent
submission from the youth council their
suggestion i thought had had a degree of
merit in it
and saying 20 kilometers per hour past
schools because that's the speed limit
that you've got to go past a bus at
that said the number of times i'm
traveling past those buses at 20 k's and
there's still vehicles whizzing past me
and two lanes is
well it hasn't happened since this
morning
there's a nice personalised plate but i
won't drop that in the meeting
so
bringing the the levels down
differently in in the rural zone to the
urban zone actu actually makes good
sense
councillor arnold makes a good point in
that with speed
quite often we're preaching to the
converted
and that there are people who will
follow a speed limit and there are those
drivers who feel that they are better
than that and have tremendous control of
a car
but that's why they're called accidents
because nobody
intends for them to happen and sometimes
that can be as a result of road
conditions
you know we're in the middle of the
drought
at the moment
and
all it'll take
is the first rain and all the oil that's
built up on the roads over the past
several weeks without rain suddenly
turns them into a nice skating rink
and so there are those unseen risks that
people aren't aware of and it's
bringing all that into mind along with
the the submissions that we heard
in here a couple of weeks ago
i can see some sense in in making the
changes um
i'm not sure whether it's a good thing
or a bad thing that it's occurred at the
same time as there's a national highways
review going on i guess there's there's
it increases awareness but people might
confuse what we're doing on a local
scale with that and actually
i guess at a higher level the principles
are the same in the rationale behind it
but it is it is a significant move
i mean the last time i remember speed
limits being discussed we changed from
miles to kilometers
uh which is a few years ago for those of
us who remember that um i mean i'm
supportive of it it's it's taken me a
while to wrestle with it and come to
terms with it but
it's going to be a staged process and i
don't think we're going to get
instantaneous compliance it's it's good
that we have been talking with the likes
of
the other stakeholders it's up to police
to enforce it not us
um interesting feedback from saint john
who talked about the route to
uh the hospital uh down ellis road
picking up on the points that were made
by the youth council in response times
disappointing that uh fire and emergency
in new zealand didn't get back to us but
you know i think we've got a good
indication from saint john anyway sarah
there are these issues that we've
that we are taking into account and what
is
a significant change
um
there was a good number of people who
had put some thought into the
submissions and
like i said i don't think we'll see
instant change but we're looking at a
behavioral change and at some point it's
got to start
somewhere and just trying to
educate is is not enough because i've
been trying that for years we'll still
be educating i ventured a guess because
it's not us that's that's writing the
tickets
and police over the first while we'll
still be talking to people to make sure
that they're aware but it does actually
create an increased burden on the driver
who
in theory is
phenomenally aware of everything that's
going on around them not their phones
not adjusting their sound systems
but
having a young learner driver in the
house at the moment who's waiting to do
his test
and having to constantly look
not only for all the hazards that they
are now and remembering
what's right what's not but there's an
additional burden there that says and by
the way when you're moving down
into some streets there's a different
speed limit
that said the easiest guide is how
narrow has that street just gotten
because if it's become more narrow odds
are it's going to be
a slower speed limit so it'll be a
period of adjustment
and
and i think it's a
it's a bold but needed leadership
move that's going to come from council
if we get this through thanks to
councillor amundsen and then council
arnold
thanks chair
um
looking at these principles i think that
they really do hit the mark
at the end of the day if we
want our city to be a city that is
pedestrian friendly is cyclist friendly
and is family friendly
then i think these are all
great moves and i think
you know 40ks might take people a wee
while to get used to
but i think that actually it's
it's something that will help keep our
kids much safer make it um you know
thinking back to when uh covert was
around and we were in lockdown and there
were families biking and walking their
dogs and taking their kids to the park
on foot you know it was great to see so
many people outside and enjoying um the
city and i think that this is a way that
we can start to bring that back
council
uh yeah just like to remind i appreciate
what all my
colleagues are saying here but i've got
right even though they look like a
target i'd like to remind people that
signs aren't targets they're a speed
limit that is the top speed you can go
not the bottom speed
so i think you know we rather
we've got to apply common sense all
drivers should apply common sense if you
don't apply common sense seriously you
shouldn't be driving to me it's a matter
of education and penalties
uh not signage and 20 million is a lot
but it's over a few years i appreciate
that but
i just remember they do look like
targets
but they're
that's the top speed that's the speed
limit
not the bottom
hemiscope
so just first of all mr chair to confess
that
um i've never actually driven a car
except with a driving instructor beside
my side and we mutually agreed that this
was not a good idea that i drive however
having said that i've been a lifetime
pedestrian and an occasional cyclist
and i want to comment on
what i see
that we are doing and that is
reprioritizing what we do
within our city limits
also that i appreciate we're also
looking at the rural
and gravel roads but particularly within
the city and saying that getting to
somewhere as fast as you can is not
necessarily the best thing that the
residents of the city should be aiming
for
because when you're doing that you're
not actually focusing on where you are
and what your purpose is you're bit so
busy trying to get there faster than the
guy in the next lane
um
the risk-taking that's involved with
that but i really want to say how
delighted i am that we are looking at
our neighborhoods and saying that our
neighborhoods are actually for people
who are not just in cars but are walking
bicycling
on their mobility scooters
all those sorts of things because
that's the true
people
of our community
that is what we should be doing is
actually being in our community and
taking the time to be in our community
not rushing from here to there so if
this slows us down 38 seconds
in a day
so what 38 seconds
half a minute
we need to take the time and if
if
people are so impatient
that they cannot add a minute to their
trip to the supermarket or a minute to
their trip to work
there's something the matter with their
thought processes and the lives that we
are living so i want to thank the
council and the council officers for
their leadership in this matter because
sometimes we do have to be the leaders
not the followers
thank you
okay
um
right i'd just like to comment that that
this does
these recommendations do show
common sense
in the fact of environmental awareness
of the driver which is great i also like
to comment on the speed reduction on
gravel roads i think that is long
overdue we've had over the years i've
been on council many some
separate submissions from
the public about dust corrugations and
damage to gravel roads dropping them
down to 60 is going to make them last
longer
and reduce those effects so i i welcome
that
now i'm going to put these
recommendations but
i
i think after all this discussion i'm
prepared to put them all as one group
does anyone
object to that they can speak up
you object to that you want to go
through them one by one there are some
of them but i don't agree with all of
you okay would you like to go through
them one by one
okay right let me get to those
recommendations
okay i'm gonna
uh group one two three and four
okay so can i have someone move those
they moved council load low seconded
counselor scout
for recommendations one two three and
four i'll put that all those in favor
all right
against
okay one two three and four
okay we're going to go to
recommendation five now and that is
to resolve to adopt the following speed
principles to guide council's decision
making on speed and that incorporates a
a through to l
pex you're moving that
second did miss cook
right discussion on that
we've already had discussion but
discussion
well you know justin said we pretty much
had our discussions um so these are the
principles
bearing in mind that um
if public
60 voted
for no change i feel that i'm going to
be against this going forward
you're against the principles yeah these
you're going to realize i don't agree
with i agree with some of them but the
way they're written as a group uh
christian five i'd have to go against it
okay all right 60 percent of air
okay that's been moved and seconded i'm
going to put that motion all those in
favor
and against
i can't serano
it's carried i'm now going to go to
recommendation 6.
move to council rabbit seconded council
ludlow
right i'm going to put the motion all
those in favor
all right
against
that's carried
right
i'm going to go the rest of the
recommendations uh counselor arnold to
you very good you're all good with that
so that's
right i'm going to put
can someone please move 7 8 9 10 and 11.
that's miss coot seconded
counselor skill
we'll put those emotions all those in
favor all right against
they are carried
now thank you very much everybody for
that
and that is well timed
um
to start the infrastructure meeting at
3.
no further
no further work so the meeting
has ended thank you thank you david and
thank you russell
right we we're beginning live streaming
so welcome to the
infrastructural services committee
once i find it here
okay we have um
apologies for this meeting again from
i think we're going to have uh
councillor sopran is streaming so the
apologies uh
from councillor crackit
and
councillor kit
and
that is all
uh moved council rabbit seconded
council lewis so i put those apologies
all those in favor all right all right
it's carried that moves on to the
first
minutes
um
of the march
march one
meeting uh someone moved that they truly
correct i'd like to move that chair
thank you council lewis seconded miss
coote i'll put their motion all those in
favor
there's carrie
uh minutes of the extraordinary meeting
15th march
moved to second those
moved council ladlow seconded
council of sofa put that all those in
favor all right against that is carrick
minutes of the extraordinary meeting
tuesday 22nd of march
moved council ludlow secondary council
hamilton
put that motion all those in favor
against that is carried
that brings us now onto an update on the
search for an emergency water supply
alastair would you like to
take a seat up there
welcome alastair
pull up a chair and a microphone
thank you mr chair i'll get you to bring
the microphone or weave it closer to
you thanks for that
and you may take your mask off to speak
if you wish
thank you
uh well this report's been prepared just
to update councillors
on the progress where we've been made
made
looking for an emergency water supply an
alternative water supply direct for
emergencies
um
pleased to say that we have actually
located a suitable underground source
although the testing didn't go
quite according to
a plan we did have some difficulties but
we can summarize by saying we have found
a suitable source
its yield is good and its quality is
better than we would have thought
however
to ascertain the properties of the
supply
the pumping test we conducted
wasn't sufficient we had failure of
equipment and we're going to have to
repeat that pump test again
and so i think at that point i'll just
stop and if um there are any questions
from councillors i'll answer okay thank
you aleister um
right questions councillors
your worship
thank you um
that's that's a great great news
actually that we've found a source it is
not to be scoffed at after
20 or so years
and
it's arrived in the nick of time by the
sounds of it too is that
course
or
is it a boar or what is the actual
physical location
alistair yes it's an underground source
located at our arua
the arua plains
just off um our siding road about two
and a half kilometers
um east of the bluff highway
uh and south of the um our rodeo village
um i've got councillor clark nix then
councillor arnold
yeah thank you chair just just one
question in the report talks
i was doing a little bit about
the future connection of the water
supply into the into the main system i
guess
as opposed to being there for emergency
services only
but surely both would would need some
sort of
connection to a mainframe wouldn't it
uh yes councillor clark you are correct
um when we first considered the um
looking for an alternative source we
didn't know where it was going to be
so we were able to work out the
connection of that supply to our
network now that we know where it is
we can investigate how we would connect
it
so i just want just just final
clarification on that so that is the
pathway we would like to go down so if
fragments say um
we do connect it up and that's that's
the way we go
will we be drawing from that drill site
or would that just be an emergency
purpose or would we have it in the main
system
and take away the
potential
floor that we get off the iridi river
right the first aim of this
investigation
was to locate a water source
to take away the risk we have of being
solely dependent on the iriti river
how we connect it whether it be an
emergency source
or
something that's working
day by day
is not an issue we have to connect it
somehow
and
probably the thinking which needs to be
quantified yet
is that we should really bring it back
to one of our our main pump station here
in the city we have to do some um
logic thinking on that but just to
connect it into the nearest pipeline
which is the bluff pipeline
is not good enough
this has to be some investigation and
consideration as to how we would
implement this supply be it an emergency
source
or a full-time working water source
into our network
and just one final question i guess
which is in relation to what you just
raised about the potential for it to
come into the bluff pipeline
um i guess you'll have seen on the radar
the future that uh
aqua culture is looking to have a
hatchery potentially in um
and
bluff that would need
some additional need of fresh water
as would potentially any green hydrogen
development in that area as well so
is that another option that we could
look to because currently our
system i understand that goes to bluff
doesn't have a lot more capacity to
increase the volumes
i'm not assuming that yes it is and the
choke point there is the capacity of the
existing pipeline
sure and so if you were to connect this
second this
new supply
direct into that pipeline
to quite a large degree that choke would
still exist
okay
i think so
um
okay council lewis
i'm just pleased too thank you thank
it might might seem a silly question but
the two bores only 200 meters or
whatever apart differences in the water
supply the das and fern
infer are effectively two aqua filter
buckets side by side or
they're quite
extensive um i've been told by the
experts that it's not uncommon to have
some difference in water quality
even
from boars that are close together but
they were for intents and purposes
drawing from the same aquifer
and obviously you can't put put a stick
down to see how deep they are
in the indication how
you hit the water from the 200 meters
whatever from the surface is there any
indication apart from the the
lack of movement or the filling rate
after the 70 days of pumping is there
any indication how deep they are because
further
north from here i know some of the
cities christchurch for example the
aquaphor has been drained out and
they've some of the people have put
extensive pores back in to try and
maintain the same water supply
any indication how deep
the
water is
likely to be effectively deeper
no i suppose this that really touches on
my comment in the report that if we were
to
utilize this supply for anything other
than emergencies such as a working
uh boar day in day out we would have to
conduct more extensive testing than we
are at the moment
i think the system that we're looking at
now
the chat and formation is not
necessarily a strata that's uniform over
its whole extent it's probably in
i'm probably not describing this
correctly but pools and they'll be
connected by
uh underground canals whose capacity we
don't know
so just how the
aquifer would perform under continuous
day by day year and year out operation
would need to be tested by more
extensive testing than we've designed
for at the moment and also
even if it's an emergency supply you
can't have it sitting there
in a state of
not being used or tested on a regular
basis because as we all know anything
that you rely on for emergencies has to
be checked periodically to make sure it
does fire when you need it thank you mr
murray this right you've made the
clarification that i really wanted you
to say so people don't jump to the
conclusion we've got unlimited water
supply suddenly on tap thank you
do i have a question
uh councillor abbott
yes um just uh being um recognition of
the three waters criteria etc etc
um if we were to either have emergency
supply or be connected to the main lines
what provision is made for treatment
yes we have in the study
considered the treatment
requirement
initially we thought
it would have to be quite extensive
treatment particularly in relation to
hardness removal a lot of bore waters
are very hard and that's easiest to
describe in terms of a consumer that you
get fur on the inside of your kettle
very hard to get a soaked lather
etcetera and that hardness has to be
removed so there's a reasonable cost in
doing that but
from the testing we've done to date
the hardness element of the water is
much better than we could have expected
so that requirement for treatment has
been removed
we would still have to chlorinate the
water and do some other minor treatment
but nothing to the degree that we had
thought earlier
right thank you for that
now ms
thank you mr chair um
at this stage have you any idea
about the recharge for from that aquifer
because this
you won't have tested it for long enough
to know
whether it's a slow recharge or
you know almost instant so to speak
what will you have to do to assess that
well
in conducting a pumping test i mean
there are other water bearing stratas
above this one this particular strata is
at 200 just over 200 meters below ground
level so it's deep
and it's likely that the recharge system
is slow rather than
fast track such as the ty1 is
we had hoped to monitor
the water levels in the
over-bearing strata above but as i
mentioned the report
through a combination of equipment
failure
and
blinding off one of the tappings into
the one of the upper stratas we couldn't
measure that so we've got to go back and
repeat the testing and monitor the water
levels above the strata we're interested
in
but you suspect it's slow slow recharge
rather than
anything different yeah one of the
benefits of an underground supply as
opposed to a river supply is that you're
not subject to the seasonal
variations which we're currently
experiencing
thank you
council clerk is that hands still up
from last time
yeah it is okay
um
any other questions
for alistair
happy to move the recommendations mr
chair uh thank you do i have a
second
council lewis um so we have the
recommendations out to receive
this report
that we improve the investigation
into
the potential develop the chant
formation aquifer
and also approve
the investigation on how we connect that
to the system
so
moved and seconded i'll put that all
those in favor all right hi
against
that motion is carried thank you
thank you alistair
takes us to the activities report and uh
on the menu tonight we've got pool parks
joints uh joint agency training day
parks week
pop-up play update
umbrella installation
water supply restrictions
stock bank upgrade critical milestone
ranks home treatment plant seismic
strengthening tree roots
interfering with storm water
and the gala street
reserve tank roofs so
what would you like to cover steve thank
you mr chair i think you've taken my
thunder
um look i just would like to make a
couple of points
the effort the team at splash palace
have undertaken
in terms of increasing participation
rates at the swim school has been really
outstanding
starting off at about 470 we now
can now report we're well over 600
young people and adults engaging in
learn to swim at splash palace and when
you look at the context of the
participation data generally that's
actually a really good result
but as we known as i've been reporting
the amount of effort they are going
through in order to get more people
through the door is increasing
with the covered restrictions also
changing but
with covert in our community too so just
a hats off to the splash palace team
there
i just want to make one other point
around the hydro slide there's reference
to
some remedial works on the hydro side
just want to say that that is related to
the old hydro slide which is under the
dive towers and so we're just fixing
that uh concrete block up it was
slightly bigger than the team
anticipated when we were pulling it out
and so we've just got to do a little bit
more room made your work but happy to
take any questions on the legendary
services right any questions regarding
steve
counselor arnold
um
you've never thought of putting an
elevator up the wider slide for more
mature people to go up and down
[Music]
it's
on the surface
oh no sorry i'll start again cancer very
good question
um
it is
it's a it's a tough one because actually
a number of councils have considered
this from an accessibility point of view
um and i understand the metro sport
facility is looking at that uh in
christchurch
uh where we get into some
challenge though is it's the warranties
and the rules and conditions that the
slide manufacturer impose on the users
of the slide
that
we we would really seriously need to
consider
how we manage that
by making it more accessible we might
actually be creating another risk
as users of the slide go down and for
those who've been down the slide and
hopefully you're one of them
it's quite an exciting ride that throws
you around a bit it does yeah
yeah yeah but you do i think um as the
when the mirror opened this last year we
did talk about how many meat pies
you burn in terms of calories for how
many rides on the slide so
it is very good for your health and
wellbeing
counselor clark
thank you chair uh just one question for
steve
the old uh perennial one uh any update
on uh anderson's house
how that's going and on the
re-strengthening and also whether
there's any progress around anderson
house about a potential use for post
strengthening
yeah thank you councillor in terms of
anderson house's capital program uh
we're on track there and erin might want
to add any more points
in terms of an update we hope to be
bringing a short update back to the ppp
committee next week
with a more full paper on
the operational plan in may
thank you
did you want to comment
thank you chair um i think the main one
that i'd just like to comment on and i
might actually put aleister on the spot
just around water restrictions rather
than me reiterating to you what he's
already told me
um but alistair are you happy just to
give the elected members a quick update
on when we think we might have to move
to that next restriction level
if we don't get rain
you need to go back to the speaker
from a meeting i attended um
this morning uh the predictions were
that if we didn't get rain we would have
to impose the second restriction
i think it was
by sunday
the 10th
yeah the 10th of uh this month
but
those are at the meeting and that
included the environment southern
hydrologist
was reasonably confident that we would
be getting rain
overnight
and while it's further out
the weather forecasts
are not guarantees but
slightly that we will get some rain next
week
as well
but if we don't get rain
and we'll know that by friday
we could have restrictions to second
level restrictions and on sunday
alistair what are those second level of
restrictions
again they relate purely to the domestic
properties
and it their second ban is to
ban all outside domestic use so the
likes of cleaning cars and even holding
a hose in the hand
is not allowed right
okay
um the question regarding where the rain
lands now we've got two sort of dilemmas
we've we've got people who
need
uh rain on their roofs to fill up their
tanks which is local rain then obviously
to get those cumin levels up in the flow
we need to water into the headwaters of
the eureki
so obviously um
looking at the weather charts myself
um
north of aurora all around there seems
to be getting a lot of rain
soon
is that uh is that right that we need it
in the further upstream rather than just
locally as well yes the iriti rivers um
recharge throughout its whole catchment
length
and that extends well beyond the
limits of the invercargill city council
so the weather forecasts that i've seen
are that there will be rain
further north of indocargo as well to
recharge the river
throughout its whole length but even so
that recharge
will be short-lived it will have to be
supported by
other rainfall events in order to
sustain the recovery it's not just one
rainfall rainfall event that will help
us yeah i appreciate that um councillor
kirk again
thank you chad and
just alistair again uh
you'll be aware that i sat in on the uh
southern regional leadership route which
discussed us last week
um and the met service advice we got
there that was was that we'd only get
less than five mills on tuesday which is
today
and nothing till about next wednesday
but clearly that landscape's now changed
hasn't it because it's been forecasting
much heavier rain in the next couple of
days
that's correct up to about 20 mils but
again they are forecast they're not
guarantees and we won't know what we've
got
until thursday friday of this week
okay thank you
right further questions for alistair
while he's here
nope thank you aleister again
any other
sorry i can't can i just respond to the
point from councillor clark on anderson
house
just as an awareness that
we are we do have a potential issue that
may give us a delay of a matter of weeks
on anderson house we are just working
through it at the moment but it's to do
with reinstatement of a section of the
roof
um we're working with heritage
architects on that um
and whether or not that needs to be
a particular product which may slow down
um
that that section of of the work
um hoping that we can come to an easy
agreement and not have that delay but
we're just resolving that at the moment
thank you aaron um councillor abbott
sorry for missing you
that's okay that's okay um i think it's
relevant to aleister i'm not sure if it
comes under his jurisdiction or not but
i'm just looking at the gala street
circular
reservoirs um
roofs and uh reading that and interested
i just wondered practically um if it
were to have vents through that shallow
concrete
covering but have vents would that not
achieve the purpose of no gas build up
and then could the roofs be painted with
a semi-permeable paint
alastair thank you mr chair and an
answer to
councillors abbott's suggestion
no i don't think it would
if you look at the circular reservoirs
you'll see that there are vents in the
walls
and i dealt with you'd get sufficient
aeration by putting
events in the roof elements themselves
right just a thought thank you
okay counselor arnold ah
yeah just on the on the same issue when
i was reading that the first thing
occurred to me was what about just a
plain concrete roof of water
yes that is an option having no painting
covering at all
if we did do that we would have a
maintenance program um an annual
maintenance program to keep it free of
uh slime and um algae growth
or spraying it to keep the um
the
the algal growth down but it is an
option
further questions or comments or
about the the other subjects we have on
the activity report yes your worship yes
um it's a bit left of field but
i was coming down from christchurch and
there was a huge lake there
and
they said it's um
boosted house values around it and they
do water skiing and
i wondered if that option had been
looked at
for where
are you talking your worship about a um
man-made facility for the water supply
yeah
i think it was
what's the town south of christchurch
did that hold out for the or is it
facing a crisis just like we are now
um well there are several cities
throughout new zealand that do have what
they call impoundment dams which are
man-made lakes
for the purposes of water supply
wellington has them
um
several cities have them
um
they cost quite a bit of money to
prepare and they're of a finite volume
and my argument
more applicable i suppose to
a man-made
super reservoir
is that they the cost of doing that
is significant and it's also it's a
finite volume where by
if we an underground supply is likely to
have a volume much larger than a
man-made lake
um
and eden does seem rather deep though
it certainly is but that depth does give
us protection against um contamination
from activity above
with the lakes
you can have issues with stratification
in them
the wellington lakes do from time to
time calling it causing
taste to nota issues
there are
problems to be overcome no matter which
system you use
we've elected to go
and search for an underground supply
it represented the best value for money
at the time
and of course if we were unsuccessful in
finding an underground supply
then we'd have to examine
other alternatives
but so far the investigation has proven
that looks likely that we can use an
underground supply
thank you i see the
i see the occasional update on the
tasman project um
it's a sort of a storage system is that
right alastair is it storage yes it's a
rather large impellment dam meant for
irrigation and for water supply for the
nelson region
and its latest update price is 180
million
so
yeah
i think we keep drilling
right uh councillor abbott
oh no i'm all good there okay
well thank you once again alistair
there are another couple of um items on
the activity report if you wanted me to
talk to while i was here
right
look we'll go for that you want to talk
about the
um
you don't you're not doing the tree
roots
no no
are the strengthening of breaks home uh
yes
that's a project my colleague mr keane
has been involved in but
it's funded by in part by the
ministry of business and innovation as a
part of the payment
given to us
for the rfi exercise
done
january of 20 2021
you might recall that
council were advanced funds for various
projects and that was one we put up
[Music]
it represents strengthening of
other critical elements of our water
treatment plant that
in today's design code weren't up to
expectations
and really what it was is strengthening
the um
the wall and floor joints
about 360 thousand dollars worth
that's substantially completed now
excellent
there might have been one other i think
i haven't got the
uh it was it was just the uh tree roots
on the drain okay awesome that's it good
yeah
okay any further questions or comments
about the activities report
with ah yes miss cook
um just to comment it going back to the
um
the umbrella
yes it's an action in here it's
completed and it's been opened and it
was wonderful and so i just want to
compliment the park's team
for the work that was done to make that
possible because i know that it had some
challenges
but
most successful and much appreciated
by the beck whanau in particular so for
all the effort that went into that for
whoever was involved
job well done thank you very much
thank you catherine
councillor and just a quick comment on
the same subject an interesting
challenge from mrs beck around matariki
indeed
which i'm sure the parks department
picked up on because i i understand that
the liaison between them and and the big
family has been outstanding and
appreciated
yeah there was also some mention of of
the um
the success of the sculpture being there
and and a thought put into many heads
that perhaps it's the site of a future
sculpture park for invercargill
just something to put into our future
thinking
i think that's a great idea councillor
sober you could almost fit a clock tower
there
[Laughter]
and and and many other interesting
sculptures mr chair yeah maybe it could
almost be a public competition
yes
obelisks
okay we've got four recommendations in
front of us it's actually five we
received the report
um
i'll move those uh all together do i
have a second to please
uh secondary counselor scout i'm going
to put those recommendations all those
in favor
against they are carried thank you
thank you steve
right that brings us now to
public excluded um
the reason for public excluded is for
the receiving of the minutes of the
1st and 15th of march also
to consider an application to extend
water distribution network along steed
street
um
can i have someone move thank you
councillor amundsen secondary councillor
scott
including
mr lindsey mckenzie
put that motion all those in
again
we're now in public excluded thank you
you